Yes it certainly was a bit smaller as it was six councillors and myself as acting mayor.
and of course David, the Deputy Mayor and two other councillors over at
Passchendaele. They're over there with
approximately forty RSA members from
around the district, so the
representation from this district in
Passchendaele is very big.
On the 12th of this month there will be at the Kaiapoi Cenotaph
there will be a
commemoration service of which, just
about all the remainder of councillors
will be there. Wendy Doody is
going to deliver a speech on behalf of
the council there.
Great to see giant steps starting to
happen for Kaiapoi on that
regeneration area. We passed yesterday
the wall in the river on the north side
of the river to be strengthened.  Ready
for the development on the site that
which used to be the Hansons Mall.  That
will take place hopefully in November,
the first sod will be turned on that.
In regards to the approval of the
stopping of the roads, that was also
passed yesterday at Council.
I think that's a huge psychological step, not only for Kaiapoi, but for the whole
district. Once those roads start to
disappear and it returns back to green
and all the the new plan starts to come
together this is really going to set
Kaiapoi back on the path of of really
being healed
We did approve $30,000 for next year
for the food forest.
Hugely successful project with the planting of trees and
250 people turning up a couple of weeks
ago to get that well underway, so now
there is some some funding in which
people can draw on and the lease is now
signed for that land.
But that's fantastic news for some very
hard-working trustees,
who have put that together.